what would you say then is the most
underrated japanese food for people to
try when they come to japan right
because like everyone obviously
everyone knows that they're going to go
to a sushi place they're going to go to
like an izakaya but like
uh the one that no one ever talks about
unanimous like the boss dude i was going
to say your nagi as well yeah yeah
please try unagi it is expensive it is
expensive it is expensive but it's worth
it
it's an experience okay because like i
remember i remember
explaining to my mom how i'm like really
into unagi but i had to explain to her
that uh it's uh eel right yeah she's
like oh yeah people why'd you like eat
well that's disgusting and that's
because like her perception of eating
eel is like jellied eels oh yeah yeah
i'm just like my god like the living in
the uk has just like ruined your
perception it's just [ __ ] s tier food
so it's like the way it's prepared is
that it's grilled and then it's like
smoked i think as well yes yeah and so
it's it doesn't it's not slimy it's just
like kind of like you know when you
grill a fish and it's kind of like nice
and crumbly and dry and and then they s
the way they season and sauce this bad
but it's not dried that's the thing it's
not somehow moist it's it's moist it's
good it's just like it has like the uh
consistency of like fish and it's like a
perfectly a perfectly good
uh perfectly good like flavorful moist
fish you put that on a bed of rice i i
feel like at the like
there's some really cheap places you can
get it but i'd say the places that cost
around two to three thousand yen for a
box are probably like the places where
you'll get some really good ones yeah
you know i've gone to places where they
charge like seven thousand yen seventy
bucks for just a place where it's like a
hundred bucks for yeah and it's like
it's like
damn it's good but can you tell the
difference in the taste though yeah i so
i it's weird man with an aggie it's like
i feel like the the subtleness of the
flavors especially the fish yeah when
you get it cheap it's so harsh the
flavor yeah yeah whereas like the good
ones the sauce is kind of light the fish
the sorry the eel is just really oh i
don't know how to describe it [ __ ] it's
ah i don't know do you know what i mean
i i know exactly i know you mean i
i don't know it kind of like the skin
also the texture of the skin on the
cheek places is like really
uh rough yeah rough and kind of yeah
it makes you feel like you're eating
something fishy whereas normally when
it's good or naggy it doesn't remind you
it doesn't feel like you're eating fish
yeah it feels like you're eating meat
yeah which is like the weirdest
comparison yeah it's it's like a meaty
fishy kind of it's like it's like a meat
and fish combo yeah the best way imagine
yeah yeah yeah you have to ever get like
ubereats unagi i've had it a bunch uh
it's generally at meh yeah i'd say you
got to go to a restaurant if you're in
japan you're probably not getting
ubereats so don't worry about it yeah
don't waste your time with uber uh i
will say sometimes that if it's a nice
unagi place you might have to reserve
unanimity takes a while to cook yeah
it's like uh a lot of places especially
if you're out in central summer summer
yes it's a summer food primarily but you
can get in winter it's still good yeah
uh the places in the countryside outside
of tokyo normally always have to call in
advance yeah and tell them that you're
you're coming or that you want to book
because it takes i think at least an
hour or two to cook it yeah though
because it's smoked and stuff so it
takes a while it's really really good
really really recommend it yeah and
people don't really talk about it
because people don't like the idea of
eels
yeah i'm always hyping it up though i
love it yeah i mean i guess for me if i
can't say unagi uh if you are going to
like a more expensive uh seafood place i
really like uni i mean yeah
i know
i know connor hates it well i've uni has
like really grown on me since i've moved
to japan like really really good yeah i
just like okay you know how favorite you
know how you know they say like if you
if you take a seashell with you and you
put your ear against it then you can
hear the ocean and hear the scene so me
eating uni is like eating the seeds it's
like tasting it's like it's you know
like if uh if the she had poop and you
ate it it would be
if the seeds were like the best flavored
poop if
i guess i'm about to play euphoria all
over again baby because i i am a seed
lover if you know what it is it's on
screen right now it says orange looking
paste thingy you'll you'll recognize it
because it always stands out in the
sushi yeah everything it looks like
one of these things is not like the
other
but it looks it's so refreshing and it's
so so you'll know which camp you're in
yeah it's
when you try it please let me know to be
fair
i think i think out of like the almost
like maybe 10 to 20 people that i've
taken to a sushi place and they've tried
uni i think like like 75 of them ended
up liking it yeah what i think it's like
most people i think are very thrown off
with how it looks i spoke to died and
emily and they were like yeah they were
like let's go to a sushi place like sure
like the one place i don't want to go is
if they have too much uni
and i was like don't worry i hate uni
too
yes that's so good no taste no taste no
taste but oh yeah like that i i really
really like uni and i even if you don't
like it i recommend you try it out
because
it's a very unique flavor it's very
refreshing it's nothing
it's nowhere on the same level as like
something like [ __ ] natto or
something like that where it's like
weird foods it's a very subtle flavor
subtle it's like a it's a sponge
no
it's like refreshing it's like eating
the ocean it's like it's like a salty
creamy type of like you know nice flavor
that goes yeah yeah
it's so weird because you literally look
at the sea urchin and you're just like
how the [ __ ] anything edible come out
of that
it's like what the hell is this they
crack it open gold
gold of the ocean
um okay i would probably recommend then
um what japan does really [ __ ] well
when when we think of meat based foods
in japan you know most people are pretty
quick to go like uh you know wagyu and
stuff like that i think they're like
tonkatsu in japan oh yeah it's god too
[ __ ] which is uh which is uh uh fried
no not fried well deep yeah like pork
dude if you ever go to gunma holy [ __ ]
these things are like yeah they look
like they're fighting back
thick pieces of pork it's so good though
oh there's this really good chain in
tokyo
i'm going to call myself yeah oh oh my
dude
[Music]
hungry like me acting off dude yeah pork
cutlet like there's there's nothing that
can be like a fresh pork cutlet
over it's my go-to yeah yeah it's just
like
the egg [ __ ] yeah like the texture is
just godly he bites in and it's all
crispy and then you get the rich inside
it's nice and juicy oh my god [ __ ] me
out god
you can have it by itself or there's
another really like cool way to eat it
which i like which is katadon which is
like where you like put it in egg and
like have some money people are a better
right yeah
i'm not a fan of katsudon really because
it's like to me to me to me part of my
like one of my favorite things about
tonkatsu is the texture right but when
you put it on the egg it just like it
gets rid of that crunch to it no but
like it's but that's replaced with the
[ __ ] amazing like egg and like pork
flour
like it's it's that crunch it's that
fresh crunch that just it's it's just
godly and by putting egg over it you get
a fresh one you can get like the crunch
with the egg and the sauce and
dude it has the crotch i can't believe
you just tell you what it is i can't
believe it tell you what tell you what
it is it's it's like putting milk in
your cereal all right
you get rid of the texture i like that
crunch i like that fresh crunch
chocolate is better than the normal uh
just katsu because you get the egg the
egg and the onions are a game changer
but with the rice because when you get
the perfect ratio of of meat egg rice
and onions in one bite like it's like
food wars levels like not hungry it's
it's the best
i don't know what god's talking about
god's little baby though god's like dude
gonna ask questions like do you peel
your crayons before you eat it like this
like i don't know don't don't trust god
i mean i mean it's it's it's it's a
prayer it's a preference thing it's a
preference i've got so to me to me the
best thing about tonkatsu is to eat [ __ ]
is that [ __ ] what you do no no no no
no he's got good taste because he likes
natto all right you want to start with a
guy who says old bread tastes the same
but i
yeah but again like i would like to
argue there is so much more to japanese
cuisine than sushi and wagyu like yeah
go ahead eat the sushi
and ramen right all [ __ ] amazing but
if you go out there and try out some
other like lesser-known stuff and
there's like we only just [ __ ]
scratch the surface there is plenty of
other stuff
yucky maybe maybe you're like oh [ __ ] i
[ __ ] with economics i [ __ ] with
okonomiyaki you know takoyaki as well
you know it kind of chooses uh yeah some
people really like it some people don't
have some really nice restaurants
actually that do it that are like really
good prices
i mean it's street food right but there
are some restaurants that do it
amazingly
but if you're gonna have some of the
best okonomiyaki and takoyaki especially
you've got to go to osaka that's true
yeah
in like this like really shitty downtown
where like five people could fit in it
and it was [ __ ] amazing well the
thing is it's just like i feel like the
rule with asian food is that if you buy
it on the streets or if it looks [ __ ]
dirty that food is gonna [ __ ] be
amazing and then and that rule is also
consistent in japan as well if you have
the if you have the opportunity to buy
street food it's not it's normally
[ __ ] amazing yeah i've got a question
what about combini food where does that
come into this combini food um
company food is an experience i think
that's really fun for the first couple
of days yeah yeah obviously you're gonna
want you're gonna want to save some
money and spend some money on
restaurants yeah i'd say yeah yeah you
could definitely try beanie food's still
great compared to everywhere else
because i'm like
i'm like compared to the rest of the
world compared to the restaurant because
like i'm remembering when i first came
to japan i'm just like damn i can live
out of 7-eleven and family members my
entire life and i did for like a good
few months and didn't get bored you guys
lived off combini like onigiri and
sandwiches yeah yeah yeah
because like compared to like the food
we have uh like [ __ ] tescos or
whatever it's like
right off yeah i'm gonna say it
i'm going to say it i'm going to [ __ ]
say okay listen right these sounds are
good they're decent but these sandwiches
aren't better than the ones i'm
reserving my judgment i still have yet
to try a tesco meal deal
i know for a fact i know when we go to
the uk for god's wedding later right
yeah i'm going to try it out and i'll
see which side i'm he's pretty scared
because i know for a fact you're going
to like the tesco meal deal more okay
but like comparing tesco food to [ __ ]
combini food it's it's nowhere near it's
nowhere near okay first of all joe
here's i'm going to tell you first of
all sandwiches actually have crust on
them okay that already wins all right
what do you what what what do you want
if you don't want a sandwich
no i'm not saying i'm okay i'm just
saying the sandwich is about it all
right okay that's that's not an argument
i'm saying conbini food in general what
do you want what do you want if you want
a tesco meal deal but you don't want a
sandwich get a salad sorry it's decent
it's not great i'm not gonna call it a
[ __ ] salad pasty if you're on pasta
it's a cold pasty a cold pasta deviled
eggs
it's like a pork ball with batter
egg no egg in the middle
you got to compare that to like [ __ ]
good good fried chicken
but the sandwich game is absolutely
appalling i still like them yeah but the
uk sandwiches are like it's like
like the sandwich there's the sandwich
in konbini's section is like also one
one tiny section compared to like
literally the
what's up with that why is that a meal
deal why is that a drink get your own
tea get a sandwich and a little snack
because you have an infinite amount of
choice out of corn yeah yeah
like just called going to the food
section at a convenience also i don't
like in japan how it's really hard to
get a normal sized bag of crisps like
they're all big sized right we noticed
that yeah it's like you can't you talk
about like the small you can't just have
like one portion of crisp it's like you
have you're committing to like three
bags yeah which would be fair to be fair
though like when you when you do buy the
big ones though like 60 of it is air
which is probably the equivalent of like
one small sized bag of chips so yeah but
yeah i mean like if especially if you
come from england uh i think connor's
romanticized tesco mu deals a lot
absolutely not because you got these
sandwiches and uh if you go to the
company you also have sandwiches but you
also have like onigiri fried chicken you
have some yakitori sticks you got bentos
i don't [ __ ] with the yakitori sticks at
conbini's i wouldn't get them you won't
get them so you get like you get like
you've got fried chicken
there before
did you get food poisoning i did not
i've had the 7-eleven like not corn dogs
the ones like just hot dogs on a stick
yeah it's all right the corn dogs at
7-eleven are kind of all right no i've
never had one i i like because i like
corn dogs this is it's hard to [ __ ] up a
corn dog if you go to a mini stop which
you won't see often they have soft serve
they are the rarest yeah although many
stuff soft serves are godliness yeah
yeah like they specialize in soft surf
and it but finding it but like mini
stops are like the ssrs
i think in tokyo i think it's only like
0.5 percent of companies in tokyo are
mini stops most of them i feel like are
around like shinjuku weirdly i see a lot
yeah
yeah i know there's one like up north
where i used to live but that was very
rare they get there i was very happy i
lived near a mini stop i was like oh yes
i've pulled the ssr let's go baby
hello so much just so you're supposed to
choice of food and how about however
much you want to spend you can spend
yeah